بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
مك
قصي ابو عوض
ابو عواد
ابو عوادبو عوض وابو
ابو عويط
داليا سحت
hereر
‏was
going to beightingli
so
and
I want you to prepare
a a por
سوره الروم مالك
سوره القمر قصي
سوره الانسان
دلوله
want
you
say 10 15es
‏I want you toite
for a small of the you
compet with you can of the you know if
that makes you moreable
but we have to people that youed it so
try to it from
no pressure all
‏Having said that tomorrow night we are
going to have
we going to have a lot of pictures taken
for our community to archive we are
trying to prepare and revamp our social
media pres and we want to document our
achievements and one of our achievements
as a community is weamdble
to come
‏people come 27thyulty
breed a culture we sque every last minut
out ofان while is with us i know the
last three ofان are us reserved for you
know get fored
and buying stuff and shopping
‏et but
have our
we want you come in want you beute
last night tomorrow night we willingر
you here
you will have the enر you that i
‏Sometimes we take this for granted. You
decided to leave off the world,
come into the
and stand in one spot
for almost 60 hours in one month doing
nothing but listening to Allah's words.
That's got to count for something
doesn't that has got to count for
something masallah masallah. ‏This is
a monumental achievement not a small
thing and one of the little changes
little tweaks that we made is that all
of the Quran wasit in the we break it up
between the regular prayers and the we
did it all in because I
our community would be strong enough and
up for the challeng ماء الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم بخاري مسلم من قام
رمضان
ايمانا
واحتسابا
ايش غفر
له ما تقدم من ذنبه
‏Now
speak
الله سبحانه وتالى
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
قياض
احت
الله
sin
what is of sin will be for
that is not
‏think will
have
to tell you if you make
the
all are for
would
[Silence]
‏for and areperate need for
here could any
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الشكور
[Silence]
‏is all thanks
servesn't
have to do this forment
الله سبحانه وتعالى
كتب على نفسه الرحمه
‏upon
mery that would have mercy on serv
and we are hereight and the pri and the
to come we are hereing
for that for that reward and to save us
from the hell fire
and you know
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏not only save
serv from the fire but he admits them
into parad a place will continue to get
better and better and better for all of
eternity to come. There's no death.
There's no more tears. ‏No more sadness,
no more heartbreak, no more fear, no
more reget,
no moreilt.
Freed of all of that.
‏When a person is admitted into
paradise,
the lower levels of paradise are
described to us in الانسان
descriptions are of the lower levels of
paradis
into three types in surق
what are those three types of
مقربون
‏people
will
because their
hand ong
and will
الله
سبحانه وتالى
الابرار
قران
سبحانه وتالى
‏that mied with
and thece of will come from
in parades
يفجرونها تفجي
‏any dire
[Silence]
have
any dire
سبحانه وتعالى
all
الله
شره مستطيرا
كان شره مستطيرا
[Silence]
spos
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فوقاهم الله شر
اليوم ولقاهم نظره وسرورا
الله
سبحانه وتالى
outحه
وى
‏to
will parad amongk
and that will them they will never heat
again they will never cold again heat
andold that are
سبحانه وتعالى ويطاف عليهم
من فضه
asوver
[Silence]
‏by together
willver
ودانيه عليهم ظلالها
وذللت قطوفها تذليver
andes
of thosees will them around they
‏deses
outحه
notes
because
‏desire being parad
there con there con
parad is of us and are of parad to the
point that your desire as soon as it
sparks in your heart that parad will
begin to will begin
‏and
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره البقره
واتوا به متشابها
‏toatch
thisch will
eaten from as takes from thisch
of grapes another will grow in
‏How is
if given enough time you'reentually get
what
what's going to happ say it you get bor
of it right not to worry because everyle
grape tes different than the one before
it everyone.
‏Why do people get to drugs?
They're trying to high they got the
first time, right? That magical high but
you can never again that's how this
works.
Nothing is as good as the first time.
‏FR you take
the next one will better and different
better and different better and
different forever
forever
you not have the exp
of seeing الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏parad
get
worse forever
الله سبحانه وتالى
سبيل
سلبي
[Silence]
‏is letter they would use sy
that
and
parad
because
drink from
‏into the
person
you are
tells us
عليهم ولدان مخلدون
‏will
by
etally
they are tove
I took you to the bestur on the most
expive
and is so tyy but the waiter
is a hobo theet
can you that with me the best
‏take any here
parad are
parad
اذا رايتهم
حسبتهم
لؤلؤا
منثورا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
عاليهم
ثياب
سندس
واستبرق
عيهم
how would
speakers here how would you
upon them
are
you know of what would the word for that
be upon them عليهم right عليهم upon them
why is
عيad
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
سندسبرق
استبرق
البرق
‏to fl
tog
of these garment they will cch the light
and shine the light a mirror
and sundus is a type
‏in
the most delicate of the finest of
willly on theirin
those suff life to worship الله will be
reward
with the finest
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وسقاهم ربهم
شرابا طهورا
اللهink
[Silence]
علينell
paradake
‏from
all ne
will all be g will was it away
pain sadness regret anger animosity
jealousy
all of it will be washed
‏more no more
inside or out now these description
these are which levels of paradise
these are the lowest levels of parad
this isn't the high levels of paradise
the idea well you know I'll settle
for that mean shs just give me that and
I'll be a happy camper ‏But is that
really how it works? Are you ever not in
need of anything and everything that you
could poss get from Allah? This is a
place where selfishness
is rewarded.
In the we to be selfless
in the we are to be what? Selfish.
‏any
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏are those areess fortunate our
not to those are more fortunate why
so that we do not
Allah's blessing upon us
in the you see someone car you say
you look to the guy with the little
lesser car than your you see a guy
‏with one you have one you look to the
guy that no you don't look to the guy
that has two this is how you focus on
your own blessing
when it comes to the here it's exactly
the oppos we don't look at people that
are less fortunate in guidance and say
well at least I'm not as bad as him no
you look to the
ابو بكر عمر عثمان علي ابو عبيده ابن
الجراح زيد بن ثابت عبد الرحمن بن عوف
[Silence]
‏I'll
human being that everyone
musl nonml guided misgided
sinful dutiful male female rich po every
human being even the props and
messengers
‏are overmation
howy
and ins this is all
your
comable
‏ang
take you
tell you to
overcome with common
and that is how small and
the is and ‏how py I was and how useless
all of thating and sweating and crying
was about this really didn't matter at
all this was just a small small in my
overall existence
the prophet
once was sleeping on a mat in جامع ابن
مسعود tells us when he woke
يا رسول الله افلا اذنتنا فنصنع لك وطاء
ماي ولدنيا
انما انا في الدنيا كراكب استظل تحت شجره
ثم راح وتركها
under
few minut
desert
‏is all time before
all the time after that tree is eternity
to come and the shade of that tree in
that desert that's where we sitting
right now
just here for a few minut make it good
make it count and then go home and leave
this place we not from here we
انء الله
يحيى
انء
‏Isn't that what
say
for the gr
soes
and come out tomorrow after we fin we
will have in after we make سنه صلاه
تراويح الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
[Silence]
و
استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا
سووا الصاف سد الخلل
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والنازعات
غرقا
والناشطات
نشطا
والسابحات
سبحا فالسابقات
سبقا
فالسابقات
فالمدبرات
امرا
يوم ترجف الراجفه
تتبعها الرادفه
قلوب
يومئذ
واجفه
ابصارها
خاشعه
يقولون انا
لمردودون
في الحافره
ائذا كنا عظما
نخره قالوا تلك اذا كره
خاسره
فانما
هي زجره
واحده فاذا هم بالساهره
هل اتاك حديث موسى اذ ناداه ربه بالواد
المقدس طوى اذهب الى فرعون انه
طغى
فقل هل لك الى ان تزكى
واهديك الى ربك فتخشى
فاراه الايه الكبرى فكذب وعصى
ثم ادبر يسعى فحشر فنادى
فقال انا ربكم الاعلى
فاخذه الله مكان الاخره والاولى
ان في ذلك لعبره لمن يخشى
اانتم
اشد خلقا ام السماء
بناها
رفع سمكها فسواها
واغطش ليلها واخرج ضحاها
والارض بعد ذلك دحاها
اخرج منها ماءها
ومرعاها
والجبال ارساها متاعا لكم ولانعامكم
فاذا جاءت
الطامه
الكبرى
يوم يتذكر
الانسان
الانسان ما سعى وبرزت الجحيم لمن يرى
فاما
من طغى واثر الحياه الدنيا
فان
الجحيم هي الماوى
واما
من خاف مقام ربه ونهى النفس عن الهوى
فان الجنه هي الماوى
يسالونك عن الساعه ايان مرساها
فيما انت من ذكراها
الى ربك منتها
انما
انت منذر من
يخشها
كانهم
يوم يرونها لم يلبثوا الا عشيه
الا عشيه
او ضحاها
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
عبس وتولى
ان جاءه
الاعمى وما يدريك لعله يزكى
او يذكر فتنفعه
الذكرى
اما من استغنى فانت
له تصدى
وما عليك الا يزكى
واما اما
من جاءك
يسعى وهو يخشى
فانت
عنه تلهى
كلا انها
تذكره
فمن شاء ذكره في صحف مكرمه
مرفوعه
مطهره
بايدي سفره
كرام
برره قتل الانسان
ما اكفره
من اي شيء خلقه من نطفه خلقه فقدره
ثم
السبيل يسره
ماته فاقبره
ثم اذا شاء
انشره
كلا لما يقض ما امره فلينظر
الانسان الى طعامه
اما صببنا الماء
صبا ثم
شققنا الارض شقا
فانبتنا نا فيها حبا وعنبا
وقضبا
وزيتونا
ونخلا
وحدائق
غلبا
وفاكهه
وابا متاعا لكم ولانعامكم
فاذا جاءت
الصاخه
يوم يفر المرء من اخيه
وامه
وابيه
وصاحبته
وبنيه
لكل امرئ منهم يومئذ
شان يغنيه
وجوه يومئذ
مسفره ضاحكه
مستبشره
ووج وجوه
يومئذ عليها غبره ترهقها قتره اولئك
هم الكثره الفجره
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اذا الشمس كورت
واذا النجوم انكدرت واذا الجبال سيرت
واذا الجبال سيرت واذا العشار طلت واذا
الوحوش حشرت واذا البحار سجرت
واذا النفوس زوجت
واذا الموؤوده سئلت باي ذنب
قتلت
واذا الصحف نشرت واذا السماء
قشطت
واذا الجحيم سعرت
واذا الجنه
برزت
ازلف فت علمت نفس
ما احضرت
فلا اقسم بالخنس
الجوار الكنس والليل اذا عسعس
والليل اذا عسعس والصبح اذا تنفس
انه لقول رسول كريم
ذي قوه عند ذي العرش ش مكين
مطاع ثممانين
وما صاحبكم
بمجنون
ولقد راه بالافق المبين وما هو على الغيب
بضليل
وما هو بقول شيطان الرجيم
فاين تذهبون
ان هو الا ذكر للعالمين
لمن شاء منكم ان يستقيم
وما تشاؤون
الا ان يشاء
الله
الله رب العالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
كبار
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
اذا السماء
انفطرت واذا الكواكب
انتثرت
واذا البحار فجرت واذا القبور بعثرت
علمت نفس ما قدمت واخرت
يا ايها الانسان ما غرك بربك الكريم
الذي خلقك فسواك فعدلك في اي صوره ما شاء
ركبك
كلا بل تكذبون بالدين ان عليكم لحافظين
كراما كاتبين يعلمون ما تفعلون
ان الابرار لفي نعيم وان الفجار لفي جحيم
يصلونها يوم الدين وما هم عنها بغائبين
وما ادرى ادراكما يوم الدين ثم ما ادراكما
يوم الدين
يوم لا تملك نفس لنفس
شيئا
والامر يومئذ
لله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
جزاك الله خير ان شاء الله
يحيى
‏minut
as
little
up
are easing out
ان شاء الله
[Silence]
আসসালামু আলাইকুম বদ হন্ডা
‏silver Hyundairacate
number V7A
62Y that is parked in the wrong place it
is parked right in front of the dumpster
and it is causing a lot of issues and
hazards so and sisters
a highra
is parked in the wrong place and causing
some haard so pleas
to your vehicle as صباح
[Silence]
in front of the garbage can on this
‏right here. Yeah. So, right here in
front of the garbage can right behind
right where kind of the road kind
of curves around the car is parked.
Yeah. So, behind the isantra
that is parked. Please move it by the
garbage cans back there. Brothers, these
are rules. Anyone that comes and
disrespects our rules, they disresect
every one of us.
‏They disresect our make that you follow
the rules. If I came and park my car
right here on the sidewalk in front of
the would you guys do that? These are
rules. You feel so please park your car
where it goes.
25. Yeah. Start. Yeah. Start at 15 and
go to 25.
[Silence]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الرحمن
علم القران خلق الانسان
علمه البيان
قال الله تبارك وتعالى في سوره العلق
واسجد واقترب
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد تب القلوب ودعاؤه
ونور الاب الابصار ودياؤه وعافيه الابدان
وشفاؤه اللهم ارنا الحق حق وارزقنا اتباعا
وارنا الباطل باطل وارزقنا اجتنابا اللهم
وفقنا لما تحب وترضاه ربح لي صدري ويسر لي
امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي
السلام عليكم
ما شاء
‏go have to
upon more and moreit
into
the namedayqu
divine
the eloqu of divine silence
سبحان الله
[Silence]
spe
الله سبحانه وى
‏and
some
are الله
silent to stayent
to allow the room for and the space for
the human experience to ‏take full
effect and blom
and so I have six or
that are coming to my mind but in the
interest of time insallah my hope is to
get through three of them and so I pray
to Allah
my
clarity and a steady heart to be able to
impress these upon all of you so that we
may all benit so the very first
‏und
lan
one
tak for
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
সুল্লাহ
name
الرحمن
infinite love and care and compassion to
the point that it is forth but it is
tempered by what the everlasting of
and so when you start anything with this
sentence سبحان الله سبحانه وتالى turns
it into a complete sentence and it turns
into active سبحان
الله
سبحان الله
سبحان الله was
if someone
has already wr them and if he does that
good deed he given 10 সুবহানল্লাহ
‏any
[Silence]
is
what
bec
‏name
what this is
having conv
الله
سبحانه وى
سبحان الله الله سبحانه وتالى
anotherرايم
لان شكرت لان شكرت ازيدنكم
سبحان الله
سبحان الله سبحانه وتالى
‏if
needكم
[Silence]
مو عليه السلام
are
موسى عليه السلام
ل شكرتم لازيدنكم
سبحان الله
رمضان
واذا سالت عبادي عني فاني قريب
سبحان الله
[Silence]
فاني قريب
‏God
so many different all things any com any
kindship
right
why god why this happen to me
if you ask question no matter what your
الله سبحانه وتالى
قريب
questionان
الله
الرحمن
الله سبحانه وتعالى الرحمن علم القران خلق
الله سبحانه وى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
كتب على نفسه الرحمه
القران
you
sent
سبحان اللهخ
‏will never ever let you
and know it will always be
one of the best things have a
year for that intimacy
عرف
[Silence]
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم جزاك الله
جزاكم الله خيرا يحيى
ما شاء الله
الحمد لله
رحمه
‏was school academy
it's scho 2.0
‏our
next is one little kid around here you
un
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوا
توكفت عند المطففين نعم
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ويل للمطففين
الذين اذا اكتالوا على الناس يستوفون
واذا كالوهم او وزنوهم يخسرون
الا يظن اولئك
انهم
مبعوثون
ليوم عظيم
يوم يقوم الناس لرب العالمين
كلا
ان كتاب الفجار لفي سجين
وما
ادراكما
سجين
كتاب مرقوم
ويل يومئذ للمكذبين
الذين يكذبون
بيوم الدين
واذا تتلى عليه اياتنا قال اساطير الاولين
وما يذك
بيوم الدين
وما يكذب به
الا كل معتد اثيم
اذا تتلى عليه اياتنا
قال اساطير الاولين
كلا بل ران على قلوبهم
ما كانوا يكسبون
كلا
انهم عن ربهم يومئذ لمحجوبون
ثم انهم
لصالوا الجحيم
ثم يقال هذا الذي كنتم
به تكذبون
كلا
ان
كتاب الابرار لفيين
وما
ادراك كما عليون
كتاب مرقوم
يشهده المقربون
ان الابرار لفي نعيم
على الارائك
ينظرون
تعرف في وجوههم نظره
النعيم
يسق قون من رحيق
مختوم
ختامه مسك وفي ذلك فليتنافس
المتنافسون
ومزاجه
من تسنيم
عينين يشرب بها المقربون
ان الذين اجرموا كانوا من الذين امنوا
يضحكون
واذا مروا بهم يتغامزون
واذا انقلبوا
الى اهلهم انقلبوا
فكهين
واذا راوهم قالوا ان هؤلاء
لضالون
وما ارسلوا
عليهم حافظين
فاليوم الذين امنوا من الكفار يضحكون
على الارائك
ينظرون
هل ثوب الكفار ما كانوا يفعلون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر سبحان
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم رحيم
اذا السماء
انشقت
واذنت لربها وحقت
واذا الارض مدت والقت ما فيها وتخلت واذنت
لربها وحقت
يا ايها الانسان
انك كادح الى ربك كدحا فملاقيه
فاما من اوتي كتابه بيمينه
فسوف يحاسب حسابا
يسيرا
وينقلب
الى
اهله مسرورا
واما من اوتي كتابه وراء
ظهره
فسوف يدعو ثبورا
ويصلى سعيرا
انه كان في
اهله مسرورا
انه ظن
ان لن يحور
بلى
ان ربه كان به بصيرا
فل
اقسم بالشفق
والليل وما وسق والقمر اذا اتسق لتركبن
طبقا عن
طبق فما لهم لا يؤمنون
واذا قرئ عليهم القران لا يسجدون
الله
اكبر
الذي خلق الله سمع وبصره عني وقوتي تطعني
الله تطني
عندك تقرا
[Arabic recitation]
والله اعلم بما يوعون
فبشرهم
بعذاب اليم
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم اجر
غير ممنون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر سبحان
رب سبحان
الله
اكبر
اكبر سبحان
رب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والسماء
ذات البروج
واليوم الموعود
وشاهد
ومشهود
قتل اصحاب الاخدود
النار ذات الوقود
اذ هم عليها قعود
وهم على ما يفعلون بالمؤمنين شهود
وما نقموا منهم الا ان يؤمنوا بالله
العزيز الحميد
الذي له ملك السماوات والارض
والله على كل شيء شهيد
ان الذين فتنوا المؤمنات
ان الذين فتنوا المؤمنين
المؤمنات ثم لم يتوبوا فلهم عذاب جهنم
ولهم عذاب الحريق
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم جنات
جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار
ذلك الفوز الكبير
ان بطش ربك لشديد
انه هو يبدئ ويعيد
وهو الغفور الودود
ذو العرش المجيد
المجيد فعال لما يريد
هل اتاك حديث جنود
فرعون وثمود
بل الذين كفروا في تكذيب
والله من ورائهم
محيط
بل هو قران مجيد
في لوح محفوظ
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر سبحان رب
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والسماء
والطارق
وما
ادراكما الطارق
النجم الثاقب
ان كل نفس لما
عليها حافظ فلينظر
الانسان
مما خلق خلق من ماء
دافق
يخرج من بين الصلب والترائب
انه
على رجعه لقادر
يوم تبلى السرائر
فما له من قوه
ولا ناصر والسماء
ذات الرجع والارض ذات الصدع انه
لقول
فصل وما هو بالهزل
انهم
يكيدون كيدا
واكيد كيدا
فمهل الكافرين
امهلهم رويدا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى سبحان ربي الذي خلق
فسو
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي
اخرج المرعى فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم لا يموت
فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هل اتاك حديث الغاشيه
وجوه
يومئذ خاشعه
عامله
ناصبه
تصلى نارا حاميه
تسقى من عين انيه
ليس لهم طعام الا من ضريع
لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع
وجوه
يومئذ
ناعمه
لسعيها راضيه
في جنه
عاليه
لا تسمع فيها لاغيه
فيها عين جاريه
فيها سرر مرفوعه
واكواب
موضوعه
ونمارق مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه
افلا ينظرون
الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى السماء
كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت والى الارض
كيف سطحت
فذكر انما
انت مذكر لست عليهم
بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر
ان الينا
ايابهم
ثم ان علينا حسابهم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ومجتر
صلانا وان شاء الله
[Silence]
استووا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر سبحانك
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له
كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
ربنا لك الحمد اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا من جا منك الا اليك
ربنا لك الحمد حتى ترضى ولك الحمد اذا
رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض
يا رحمن يا رحيم
رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما
ربنا اننا نعوذ برضاك من سخطك وبمعافاتك
من عقوبتك
ونعوذ بك منك لا نحصي ثناء
عليك انت كما اثنيت على نفسك اللهم صل على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ال ابراهيم
انك حميد مجيد
اللهم اننا
عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك
او علمته احدا
من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جاهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه ومن يؤتى الحكمه فقد
اوتي خيرا كثيرا
وما يذكر الا اولي الالباب
اللهم طهر به قلوبنا
اللهم حرق به شياطين شياطيننا
اللهم
اسقل به قلوبنا
واسلل به سخيمه قلوبنا
اللهم
اننا نسالك الجنه وما قرب اليها من عمل او
قول ونعوذ بك من النار
ونعوذ بك من النار
وما قرب
اليها من قول او عمل اللهم اعتق رقابنا
ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
من النار ربنا اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
من النار
اللهم كفر بالقران العظيم
ذنوبنا
اللهم اجعله شافعا مشفعا فينا واجعل خير
ايامنا يوم نلقاك فيه واجعل يوم موتنا يوم
نور
يوم راحه يوم انس يوم تنفيس يا رب
العالمين
ربنا يا حيي يا كريم
يا ان يستحيي من عباده اذا ما رفعوا اليك
اكفهم
ان تردهم خائبين
صفرا ها نحن نرفع اليك اكفنا
الضعيفه
الذليله
القليله ها
نحن نرفع اليك اكفنا
ونتبتل
اليك تبتيلا
يا رحمن يا رحيم
يا رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما
ربنا ارحمنا
ربنا اغفر لنا اللهم لا تدع لنا في هذا
الجمع ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته
ولا مرضا الا شفيته
ولا مريضا الا شافيته ولا كثيرا الا جبرته
ولا وحيدا الا انسته
لا انس الا انسك
اللهم لا
انس الا انسك
انسنا بانسك
اسكن سكنا بسكينتك
ارحمنا برحمتك اغفر لنا بمغفرتك
اللهم لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا
الا قضيته ولا مهموما الا فرجته ولا
مكروبا الا نفسته ولا كسيرا الا جبرته ولا
مريضا الا شفيته اللهم لا تدع لنا منا
المسلمين احدا من امواتهم الا رحمته ومن
احيائهم الا جبرته ونصرته اللهم اننا
نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر فر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا
اليك غير مفتونين
ربنا احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا
اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم اجمع
قلوبنا وشملنا على دينك وعلى طاعتك وردنا
الى صراطك ردا
جميلا
واهدنا واهد بنا اللهم ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا وذرياتنا
قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اماما
ربنا
اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار
اللهم
تقبل منا صيامنا
وقيامنا
وركوعنا وسجودنا
وتلاوتنا
اللهم اللهم ارزقنا تلاوه كتابك اناء
الليل
واناء
النهار
اللهم اجمع قلوبنا عليه اللهم
اجمع قلوبنا عليه اللهم علمنا سنه نبيك
واجعلنا من انصارها
اللهم اللهم طهر جمعنا من البدع والخرافات
والخزعبلات
ربنا اننا نعوذ بك ان نشرك بك شيئا ونحن
نعلم ونستغفرك
لما لا نعلم ونستغفرك
لما لا نعلم يا رحمه رحمن يا رحيم
يا رحمن يا رحيم
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر سبحان
رب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
سبحان
نديم
‏hereight
hereers
here all timeful
things
for isi
goal et unforun his family has been in a
car accident in austr and what it seems
is that kind of severe.
الله سبحانه وتعالى
close
وىoudver
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
جزاكم الله خيرا اللهم امين
[Silence]
الله يرض لا
لا
[Silence]
السلام